hello everyone so when I talk about
machine learning systems I'm thinking
about those that are in production
rather than those that are sort of
one-off data science projects not to say
anything bad about those but this is
really the focus of this talk so what
are machine learning systems in my view
there are living systems both
influencing and reacting to their
environment at best they're valuable
resilience functioning systems composed
of many in perfect parts with many weak
contracts between them built by fallible
individuals with broken communication
channels amongst them living in a
resource-constrained world that's
constantly changing the results of which
are consumed by capricious and exacting
individuals in short this is very hard
stuff I'm very thankful to be here today
it's a great honor to speak in front of
you I also had the honor of being one of
the key notes at the last PI data so the
organizers have presented a major
challenge to meet essentially give a
completely different talk to the same
audience in the space of one year so
I'll do my best you've heard a bit about
me or ready from Fernando I thought I'd
leave you or at least start off with a
graphic that would maybe shock you out
of your lunch stupor this is does anyone
have a guess what this is it's Pluto
yeah one of the new Pluto images from
the new verizon project run through
Google's deep dream and if you stare
really carefully you will freak out so
the reason why I'm showing this is
because in some sense this is the
confluence of Who I am I've been doing
machine learning and production in the
context of academia for well over a
decade and as you heard from Fernando
started a company that's doing machine
learning not quite as a service and
slightly different way and so this is
sort of the marriage of those two worlds
visualized for you again just to freak
you out of course through those that
actually know me they'll know that I'm
not
Solar System expert nor am I a deep
learner expert but this is the closest I
could do in some sense that work that
I've done in the past both in academia
and Industry informs some of the things
i'll be talking you to today about but
the point of departure from this talk
really is this paper that came out by
folks at Google called machine learning
the high interest credit card of
technical debt and one of the things
that I think is very shocking that paper
by the way is probably even more
shocking than the image that I just
showed you for those that are
practitioners and it's certainly worth a
read is this quote that you see up there
it may be surprising to the academic
community to know that only a fraction
of the code is actually doing machine
learning amateur system might end up
being at most five percent machine
learning code and at least ninety-five
percent glue code so when we think about
machine learning and we think about the
innards of machine learning and the
algorithms and the theory behind it when
you start thinking about machine
learning in practice in real living
systems it tends to be a very small
fraction of that by the way that we're
glue code should be a bit of a trigger
point for you because that's where
Python starts to come in python is a
wonderful blue code to all the different
projects and implementations perhaps at
a lower level programming language and
allows us to expose that to a broader
audience so I'm not going to go in and
sort of summarize and give a talk around
that paper but just some of the
highlights for me are the following the
idea that there are complex models that
effectively erode the abstraction
boundaries between the different
components of that model and that's the
data dependencies which are more
expensive than actually the code
dependencies which is somewhat unusual
if not completely novel for software
engineers it's a system of spaghetti
code that has to interconnect and again
it's interrupting and interacting with
the external world so again this paper
is well worth the read it's good summer
reading it's going to be on the test so
please do read it
alright so what's the agenda for today's
talk it's to discuss in some sense from
the inside out from the algorithms the
software you know to the hardware that
the software has to live inside of and
then of course as we start thinking
about Hardware in the modern era modern
hardware is basically composable and
programmable with software so we've got
another layer around that and then we've
got the people that actually build this
stuff and care about this stuff and
maintain it they of course are only
doing this because it would be crazy to
do it by any other means or for any
other means with a consumer in mind and
so the result of a machine learning
project or machine learning system in
production must have the end user in
mind and then of course there is
societal the impact to everything that
you wind up doing in machine learning
the society could be at the
organizational level of the company
that's surfacing it and it could
actually be something that's even larger
than that in some sense we heard from
this morning's keynote about some of
these systemic issues of dealing with an
understanding machine learning and some
of the trade-offs that we have to wind
up making software in this in this world
in this world view is is connective
tissue between the hardware and it is
the thing that's instantiating all the
theory and surfacing it or at least as
part of the original layer surfacing it
back out for all of us to be able to use
it so I'll sort of go into a few aspects
of these different components I'll
present some of the new facilitating
tools that I in my group and others have
been building to sort of help with these
components and then talk about sort of
the impact of how you do problem
definition in the context of this and
also in the context of teams so of
course many of you will see your
favorite algorithm or sets of algorithms
on the left hand side many of you won't
see that and you'll get mad at me and
that's completely fine this is just
examples of the kinds of things that we
all know are being used in practice in
machine learning systems and the
wonderful thing about where we've
arrived as a community
in Python is that there are some really
great packages that that are exposing
these amazing algorithms that have these
wonderful properties and I think it
should be clear to anybody here that you
know despite the proved ability of you
know some algorithm being convex you
know on paper until it gets exposed at
the software layer and until it actually
gets run in real-world hardware it
really is sort of vaporware and so in
some sense software is where the rubber
and theory hits the road and practice
what I wanted to point out though is
that we start thinking about growing out
of these layers from just getting out of
out of theory land there's a really
wonderful blog post that jon langford is
now in Microsoft Research wrote i think
it was in 2007 entitled all models of
learning have flaws unless we forget
that our favorite model or classes of
models that we like to use to solve our
problem actually have some fundamental
flaws with them and so this is a couple
of images that are basically subversive
to a well-trained deep learning model
that basically trained basically trick
it into saying something the other thing
that's obviously too much detail to go
into for this for this talk I just
wanted to point out is that oftentimes
we can convince ourselves that these
algorithms that seem to work really well
in our own data and we've got some
beautiful held out testing data when
they actually are then applied you know
almost I don't even say transfer
learning you just take an entire model
and you apply it to a completely
different data set that should work
because you've told people that I have
bounds on my errors in the context let's
say of images don't work or at least
they don't work nearly as well as people
think they are because there is no
guarantee when you build a model in
machine learning that even that you've
got testing errors there's no guarantee
that's actually going to work when the
distribution of the data actually ones
up changing so this is a couple of
different a couple of different projects
and training sets
on which you can build these very large
classifiers to predict the word car
basically from an image and what you end
up seeing in a diagonal is what was the
reported testing error for those
projects and then if you actually apply
that same model to the other sets of
images and you look for the word car you
wind up noticing that the testing errors
is actually much worse or that is the
this is these are actually accuracies
the accuracy is much worse so compare
28.2 to 10.6 and you wind up realizing
that something is really wrong for a
paper that is basically said these are
our errors and this is how well we do
relative to everyone else by the way
does anyone know what the original sort
of adversarial image is for deep
learning I found it actually in the
literature it's from the greet in 1929
he wrote this up in ICML only a few
people got that that's ok so really the
question is as you're building out these
systems what are you optimizing for and
if we start again from this inner part
of the onion and move ourselves out
words obviously at the algorithmic level
in the model level you want to you want
to think about learning rate you want to
think about convict convexity you want
to think about error bounds you want to
think about scaling and all those things
are really important and people write
papers in the academic literature that
says my scaling curve is better than
your scaling curve give me a PhD and
that's ok but when you're thinking about
that typically those are the things that
you end up caring about and you forget
about things in terms of the trade-offs
between the accuracy that you're going
you're going to wind up obtaining and
the memory usage and the disk usage and
the CPU needs and the time it takes to
learn at the time it takes to predict
these things don't show up very often
when you're just thinking about theory
and that's again ok but it's a smaller
view of where you need two of the things
that you have to care about so and then
at the project level and the people that
are minding over not only the
construction of these systems but the
maintenance of these systems it's what
is the time to actually in
plement one of these projects think
about it this way if I could give you a
perfect spam filter would you take it
and you can't answer that question
truthfully because I haven't told you
how long it's going to take me it could
take me the age of the universe and I
guarantee it's going to be perfect or
maybe something less time but you get my
drift you can't talk about building
something with a you know that has
perfect properties and not think about
all the impact on resources what is the
what is the impact on people costs what
is the impact on their time what is the
reliability of these algorithms how
robust are they to the changing world
are they maintainable can you do
experimentations with them easily and
we're not done then start thinking about
something even broader what are the
things that consumers actually care
about from these machine learning
systems they want direct value they
don't care about really what's happening
under the hood they want usability many
times you actually need explain ability
in why you got to a decision that you
got you'll hear time and time again from
some of these large corporations that
have been using machine learning in
production for decades that they're
using linear algorithms and the reason
why they're using linear algorithms is
because the CEO can understand it and
what it doesn't work they can explain to
the stockholder as well you know there's
a plus B times X and that's it try to
get that into production when you have
an incredibly complex model with
thousands of dimensions you have some
non linear mapping over that and that
just gets harder and harder and harder
explain ability for real consumers in
the real world turns out to be one of
the most important things for machine
learning and production and then of
course at the societal level what are
the direct impacts of the existence of
this machine learning system in
production I think that the big view
here is that you know if you have a
narrow view of just one part of this
this component it can be very very
costly when you actually start putting
it into practice farther up the stack so
I'm going to sort of pick apart a couple
of things around say accuracy still sort
of staying close to the algorithmic
level and then also start moving more
more in towards the hardware when it
comes to optimization we have to ask
this question what is the metric that I
really care about so this is something
that we did within my company it's a
hundred dimensional space that we've
done a regression problem we're
basically predicting a certain number
and you know it looks pretty good if you
look at the you know the r-squared it so
point 91 you can come up with some other
metrics you know root mean square
etcetera and all this stuff looks really
good right so I'm done right in fact
this is the best that I could do but
what I haven't told you is what I
actually really care about maybe I want
to minimize the scatter about this line
maybe I care a lot about the bias in the
numbers that are predicted to be below
zero and maybe that's where all the
value is for me and maybe I don't want
to ever be wrong about outliers so until
I tell you what it is that matters you
can't just throw your data into an
algorithm get an answer and move on I
think throughout this conference you've
been exposed to these so-called ROC
curves receiver operator characteristic
curves where you're plotting miss
detection rate versus false positive
rate it's basically a type 1 or type 2
error and typically what people want to
do is minimize all this stuff to the
bottom left to get a very good
classifier right and for some reason
well I know why but it's kind of weird
this is called area under the curve and
you want to maximize that so the larger
the number is closer to one the better
you go all the way down to the bottom
left with these curves so who can do the
inner the integral in their head and
figure out what's got the smallest a you
see everything's red okay who thinks who
thinks blue green okay everyone's
sleeping it's red okay so red is the
best one you want to you want to
basically minimize your false positives
while you also minimize your false
negatives so which one do you choose
which one you put in production this
isn't quite fair it's a bit cheeky I
haven't told you what the question is
yet so you can't answer that my auc is
better than your a
see but here's the reason why I would
choose a blue curve over a red curve or
a green curve over a blue curve let's
take two extreme examples so if I have a
product that works in the intensive care
unit and I want to make sure that the
people that are connected to this thing
basically when they have some problem
with you know something in their cranium
and you get a lot of expansion you want
to make sure that the nurses are alerted
to some extra pressure in the brain this
is actually a real world problem and so
you can build these systems that
basically come up with alerts and of
course you want to minimize the number
of false alerts but you don't want to
you don't want to miss too many of these
actual alerts right so in that case
where do I want to be on the curve well
I don't want to have any missed
detections because then the patient dies
and for that I'm willing to give up on a
whole lot of that AUC and I have to
choose the green curve right sorry I
have to choose the blue curve so with
the blue curve my false positive rate
can be very very high but I have zero
miss detection rates likewise if I'm
setting up some let's say drone system
and I want to shoot down enemy planes
and not my own drones I probably want to
be on the other curve and the other
curve is one where I'm willing to take a
large miss detection rate just so I
don't blow up my own stuff my false
positive has to be 0 and minus detection
rate has to be whatever it has to be to
get that to get there so if you can't
define your loss function you can't
optimize and if you can't optimize then
basically you're fishing accuracy winds
up coupling in real-world systems not to
other properties of how this thing's
scales of course it does that at some
level but the thing that you have to
really care about is some notion of
implementing if I can't put this stuff
into practice it doesn't matter how good
it is on paper so I think one way to
illustrate this is by looking at both
the netflix prize which i think is now
about 10 years old as a million-dollar
prize to try to get people to improve
their recommendation engine by ten
percent and the team that won
one basically with a few decimal places
better in the metric that Netflix cared
about over on the other teams what I've
done here is I've taken both the netflix
prize and all the public leaderboards
from that and all the public
leaderboards from all the Kegel prizes
that have ever been done which was sort
of running Netflix like prizes and you
can split this up between you know very
valuable prizes and not very valuable
prizes and I've normalized it by
whatever the winning metric is so if
it's a number they're trying to minimize
you know I basically reverse the
normalization so all this stuff should
be largely on the on the same scale
because again what the way that Netflix
is it was evaluating the way that Kegel
is evaluated is with typically a single
number and what you wind up seeing is
that there are lots and lots of teams
for these expensive prizes that get
within some normalized metric of the
final answer and they do really really
well for the ones that aren't very
valuable you wind up seeing fewer teams
actually participate and fewer high
quality teams participate so which one
do you wind up implementing if you get
within you know epsilon of the of the
best answer you could possibly get maybe
somebody who came in second place has
essentially a linear classifier and you
could write this at twelve lines of code
and maybe the one that went up winning
has some incredibly convoluted
classifier that would take a long time
to do so so when you think about the
trade-off between accuracy and putting
things into production you have to be
mindful of this and Netflix themselves
saw this in spades those of you that
know the history of what happened after
the netflix prize was given out is I
think they figure that it would take
about a hundred man years to put it in
production the winning algorithm and I
encourage you to read this blog post by
Xavier and Justin on just what they
learned out of that they looked at all
the different pieces of that code that
was one of the requirements of that of
that competition and they realize there
are a couple of cool things they could
take from that it just didn't justify
putting it in production now you could
say this was a complete failure in some
sense it sort of launched the data
science competition world if not sort of
had a bigger impact on data science more
broadly but you could also say well
bucs was a pretty small price to pay for
netflix to not have to throw tens of
person-years data science years at
trying out a bunch of stuff they just
got everybody else to try it out for
them so it's not clear that this was
obviously a failure so putting
algorithms into production is absolutely
critical in my company at wise i/o we
went up realizing that the kinds of
things that we wanted to do for learning
algorithms we weren't able to do at the
time on existing public code bases and
existing implementations of algorithms
and what you wind up realizing is that
while these algorithms work really well
on paper until you start putting them
into computers and start dealing with
issues of RAM you wind up realizing
there's a lot of inefficiencies out
there so this is a kind of very big
picture view of the sort of core ml
stack within the company is of course is
orchestrated a much larger environment
with containerized data science
workflows etc that that interconnect
with the rest of the world but we needed
fast memory efficient scalable
composable data science that we could
actually do on a laptop and then move it
into the cloud very easily and really
the end goal of the company from a sort
of data science perspective and
engineering more broadly is to have our
implementation folks manage that entire
setup so it's not the data scientists or
the engineers that are working on and
setting up new clients where we
basically wind up seeing the difference
between customers from the back end is
the difference between config files so
what our API was meant to do from the
very low level was reduced the friction
of common tasks and data science like
subsetting cross-validation computing
ROC curves etc and we really focus a lot
on computational efficiency so most of
the work that we've done is at the C++
level in the form of something we call
wise data set which will spend a little
time on and wise transfer and then I'll
also talk about this other component
called wise wind tunnel both of which
we're hoping to get out into the open at
some point some of these things are
pretty new especially
why's a wind tunnel so we're going to
work on it a bit but I've already
started talking to many of you in the
audience about it so let me just talk
very briefly about wise data sets and
sort of how they're laid out again we're
trying to be able to do most of this
work very efficiently in C++ the idea
here is that once I've laid out the data
very well and intelligently in memory
then I can build fast algorithms against
them again in C++ and really I think one
of the highlights of what we've done is
we take a given data set say in CSV land
and we pre parse it into what we call
variable variable groups so all the
things that are ants go into one
variable group all the things that are
strings go into other variable groups
and you can keep track of those at a
metadata level so that you wind up
having mappings between you know and
actually mappings between the strings
and the ins for instance so that when
you're doing comparisons you're doing
them with in sand not with strings and
the nice thing about it of course is
that this is an abstraction layer that
the Python folks don't have to really
think about it just gets exposed to them
and I'll show you what that looks like
the cool thing also is that we can have
because we've abstracted a notion of
what these different data types are we
can simultaneously store dense versions
of our columns and sparse versions of
our columns the way the surface is back
up into the Python land is something we
call using something called wise
transfer see if I can get that to work
so you can see how that actually looks
and the goal here is to move as little
data as possible from C++ land back into
Python land we found that we had to do
something like that and so we also had
to play around with transferring data
across from C++ into Python and we wound
up realizing that all the various
implementations of this like protobuf
set cetera really didn't work there were
enough limitations on those that we had
a build our own transfer protocol so we
can we can basically transfer arbitrary
data and arbitrarily serialized C++
stuff back up the
stack if we need to and so we try to
make this as easy for the data
scientists to be able to use without
having to think about all the stuff
that's happening under the hood so you
see here we basically instantiate a data
set and the important thing that isn't
clear from what you just saw is that
train and test which were part of
basically a stratified sample aren't
copies of the data they're just copies
of pointers into c++ land so we're
effectively just creating views on the
data and allows us to operate again very
efficiently in c++ land so where does
this live it's funny because you know in
the 80s everybody wanted to be a DJ I
feel like now everybody wants their own
data set abstraction we did that as well
this is somewhat opinionated backed up
by our own internal tests against these
various different implementations
starting started from the far left to
the far right it's the sorts of things
that data scientists care about down to
the sorts of things that implementation
engineers C++ folks care about so
slicing induces copy is a really
important one if you've got a big if you
got a big part of the data and you want
to sort of build let's say a train test
for a holdout set just by slicing your
original data if you have to make a copy
if that data is very large that becomes
problematic immutable columns things
like queries transfer between Python and
and the lower levels that's actually
very important as well that's something
that spark data frames is doing quite
poorly right now c++ SDK it means that i
can write against these data set objects
at the low level is it distributed is
there a memory efficiency with the way
that you've laid data out in memory have
you optimized the sort of notion of what
categories are of those data sets and
again can you use sparse and dense at
the same time so this isn't to say that
what we've built internally is a panacea
but for us building very fast machine
learning algorithms that are memory
efficient without giving up accuracy and
having to me
trade-offs is I think really really
important okay so let me move on to a
somewhat sort of larger view of this
system and that's about enforcing we
contract between the sort of lower
levels of the system and the higher
level ones I mean in some sense this is
really how we monitor deployment so
here's sort of a very generic example
that those of you that are working with
ml systems in production probably know
about pretty well so I build a data
science workflow on a test set I like
the offline testing accuracy so I'm like
great i'm going to deploy it and i'm
going to start monitoring the results in
practice and of course because it's how
i've set up the problem online when we
actually start looking at the results
it's worse than we expected from our
offline test so what do we do well you
can bang your head and say well I over
fit on the model I'll go back to the
drawing board i'll do some more data
science and that's probably fine I can
just retrain because more data is better
answers you know you've probably heard
that a lot of times it's sort of Peter
Norvig thing or maybe it got worse
because there's this thing called
concept drift that the underlying data
distribution changed the model that
approximates the predictions you wanted
to make should indeed get worse so if if
if you've built up a data science
workflow that let's say hard codes which
features you want up using and you're
not doing automatic feature selection or
automatic hyper parameter optimization
you can wind up basically hurting
yourself quite a lot if it turns out
that pond retraining where you figure
out those other parameters you still get
a pretty bad answer in production you
can go back and sort of change that data
science workflow maybe you realize that
new features that you hadn't thought
about it become important or maybe just
maybe that's okay because your
prediction influence the outcome right
that was the goal in the end of what
these ml systems are if I'm making
predictions as we heard earlier today in
the context of stripe and John types of
payments from from Mike you know if
you're basically making predictions
about whether this transaction is going
to be fraudulent and you don't let what
you think are going to be fraud
transactions through the next time you
go and retrain unless you're being very
very careful you've basically influenced
the world and so there's something about
the way the data looks today that's
different than the data that it looked
yesterday and so when you try to glom
all that stuff together you get a really
strange view of the world so there's a
lot of people obviously thinking hard
about these problems and real companies
that are putting real ml systems in
production are thinking about this
probably as the forefront of the things
that they have to care about to get good
answers there's also very good talk by
Chris yesterday on a a testing and a/b
testing that's relevant to some of this
discussion but there's there's more of
course there's obviously the testing
that you normally do because all of you
are awesome across your entire software
stack you've got unit tests regression
tests you're looking at integration
tests etc but then there's also sort of
I'll call a semi new concept at least in
the Python world we heard yesterday from
tre about a couple of cool tools that
are helping along these lines basically
is the data changing and are my
predictions different than they should
be given that changing data is the
contract that I set up with the larger
software infrastructure that I've set up
affected by that changing data and then
there's sort of another component of
this I'm still kind of trying to get to
the words myself of model deployment
testing I need to know when things are
too different than they were before I
need to alert a human and then I need to
use automated tools to try to isolate
the cause of that change was it data
that changed and that's sort of what the
ETL stuff gets you or was it the code
that changed because again you're not
deploying a machine learning system in a
production and then walking away and
looking at it every year you're
constantly deploying new things into the
into the system so you need to make sure
that you're not actually introducing new
bugs and new errors that other parts of
the stack didn't know about so we built
this thing in pure python called wise
wind tunnel and the idea here is that if
you start from a known good
implementation of a known algorithm and
then you start monkeying with it and
start adding bells and whistles and
things in some ways you can basically
start understanding whether the data
that you're throwing through you're
getting
the answers out that you expected right
given the fact that I've made changes so
instead of hard-coding the AJC should be
this value or the accuracy should be
this value say within some constraint
instead the way that we allow ourselves
to do it at the decorator level is to
say the auc shouldn't change by more
than a few sigma where we've defined
what a few sigma is from the previous
run using different random seeds given
the same data set that has to be true
but it's not just testing on things like
accuracy we're also testing on things
like memory usage and total time it
takes the train total time it takes to
load data into memory and so when you
start doing that you get sort of a
probabilistic inference about how well
you're doing relative to what you had
before now you still have to have
something at the very beginning that you
wound up trusting but to the extent that
we're thinking about this is almost like
a get project everything that we do when
we do a new deployment becomes sort of a
nougat hash and allows me to go back and
reproduce the code that got us those
exact answers along with the same seeds
so we can go back and make sure that
we're not messing anything up unexpected
surges in memory cause crashes for
instance and you can you can protect
against that or at least test against
that and that can be as critical as
protecting against loss of accuracy so
when you think about these weak
contracts between the different layers
here one way to think about is that the
abstractions of how you think about the
implementation of your algorithm in the
context of the world that you're you
sort of have heads down focus on those
abstractions wind up leaking into the
other parts of your system so one thing
that Leon Bhutto basically said it I mcl
along those lines he started came up
with the very clear example I think that
illustrates this sort of leakiness very
well you've got a smart programmer which
makes an inventive use of a trained
object detector recognizer the object
detector recognizes data that it hasn't
seen before and it produces an answer
and then this smart programmer basically
gets an answer that's complete garbage
and there's nothing in the way that we
think about say an algorithm and deep
learning that protects us naturally
against this we have to build larger
systems around this and why is that I
mean it's not just because these you
know the theory is really bad on for
this algorithm or that algorithm the way
that Google the Google paper put it is
machine learning packages are inherently
a tool that mixed data sources together
and because they are doing that you
create entanglement and that
entanglement is very hard to take out we
have not software to blame for this or
theory to blame for this we have data to
blame for this we like to think when
we're building out our algorithms of
this sort of platonic form the sort of
crystal and sphere of of data but real
data is not platonic it's plutonic sorry
I had to do it it's ugly it's a dusty
snowball with mountains and warts and
geysers and it's got Nan's and missing
quotes and all that stuff it is
incredibly ugly but at the same time
it's incredibly rich if we wind up
looking at say one document or a series
of documents you want up realizing that
the different pieces of that data
require different sorts of attention in
the future ization of it so you've got
natural language processing which could
produce very sparse output we've got
computer vision which may be sort of a
nested thing you've got metadata which
can produce sort of dense output time
series so there's a concept of streaming
and of course if you're pulling over
third-party data about this many times
that turns out to be missing and noisy
so the richness is wonderful and what
you wind up what you wind up realizing
is that to do this right do this feature
ization correctly you need to have very
deep domain knowledge and so doing
machine learning without that knowledge
is very is very painful and in fact may
even be too hard and when you think
about domain knowledge and you think
about your requirements of having that
it's some sense what you're really
asking is are you at are you asking the
right question how many of you know a
botanist
wow that's amazing are we like near a
big botany school or something I wasn't
expecting at all I was expecting
crickets so the reason why I'm asking is
because there's this famous machine
learning data set it's the hello world
of machine learning called the iris data
set where you have to predict the
different types of viruses who's asked
the botanist of those that Noah botanist
do you even give a crap about that I've
got this amazing classifier it's got a
hundred percent accuracy and I can take
an image of a and they'll say no I don't
care about that right who's asked
themselves or maybe somebody else about
the provenance of this data how come
they're no errors on the length of the
of the pedals where all these data
points taken of the sort of same area
with the same type of soil at exactly
the same time after they were planted
know or we don't know right we need to
we need to start asking ourselves about
about questions that are actually
important not to say that this isn't a
interesting data set as a hello world
but this doesn't actually have any real
value in because it doesn't have any
real value it's hard to find what the
real loss function is over that data one
of the things that we found very hard in
our academic work was the recognition
which should be clear to all of you as
me being essentially a trained physicist
that I'm not a machine learning expert
i'm not a statistician by training and
so for me to be able to answer these
questions in a production environment
that mattered i needed to find people
that were really good at the things that
i wasn't in the computational sciences
sort of specifically i could ask the
domain questions but then getting those
people essentially build these
large-scale machine learning systems so
that we could answer really important
scientific questions was hard what I
started realizing after we started
building some paper some projects around
this in astronomy is that when you look
at time series data in the sciences
there's a lot of commonality from
neuroscience the seismology and the way
that we started thinking about building
out a proud
checked in astronomy we started
realizing some of the same tools that we
were going to need to do that we're
going to be broadly applicable to those
in five minutes okay we're going to be
broadly applicable to those in in in
other sciences and so what we did is we
got a grant for the National Science
Foundation to basically build a platform
for domain scientists to very quickly go
through and get some central feature
ization off of Time series data to be
able to build out the scientific
projects on time series data and answer
questions that they want to ask
themselves without having to spin up a
whole team of domain experts in machine
learning and Institute six so it won't
go into the details of this this project
is on is on github and we're certainly
very happy to have people contribute to
that one of the things that we're really
excited about is the way in which we do
continuous integration basically
leveraging docker and we've been very
thankful and fortunate to have Microsoft
Azure devote some time on their cluster
for us to be able to work what was the
output of this we wanted to produce
basically some of the scientific papers
that we we put out several years ago
with the same data sets raw data sets
with essentially just a couple of clicks
of a button and our nvp which we're sort
of now arriving at is our ability to
produce results that are comparable to
the ones that we had before so one of
the things to recognize is that you know
making predictions let's say about the
classes of variable stars is you know
one thing but you really want to use
that as a launching off point to
something else of some sort of deep
interest so based on all of the work
that we did in the past where we
classified tens of thousands if not
hundreds of thousands of variable stars
we are able to find some really
interesting needles in a haystack that
were essentially impossible to find by
any other means and I won't go into the
details of all these things but the
the point of this is that we basically
had a end goal in mind we had we had
something that we really cared about
which is pushing the envelope of
knowledge and in doing so we had to do
machine learning I didn't do this
because machine learning is fun I mean
it is fun but it is really hard and one
of the things that we all have to ask
ourselves is you see this data set you
say I've got this pretty awesome hammer
I'm just going to start hitting it
because it looks like a cool nail there
is a real danger it's starting off and
trying to solve problems with with
machine learning systems before you
actually think about the problem deeply
and can you solve it in other ways in
the company at wise we're basically
selling products into the CRM world with
a non-technical buyer and a non
technical user and we're basically
focused on routing say support tickets
when you send an email to a company
there's a lot of people that have to
look at it and optimizing and automating
that is that is the domain problem that
we decided we're going to solve what you
want up realizing whenever you're
solving some sort of large machine
learning problem even if you're doing it
well is that you're still going to make
mistakes and the way that you make
mistakes and don't shoot yourself in the
foot is you build what's called fault
tolerant machine learning on gmail is
sort of famous for doing this really
well I've categorized this message as
spam if it's not spam that's okay tell
me why and you know next time I go back
you know I'll basically build a slightly
better spam filter for you Microsoft
Kinect uses random forests and you know
if I get the pixel wrong of is this the
left thigh or the right thigh the next
frame whatever your the right you get it
right it's not a big deal it was this is
sort of a view of what it agencies
within Zendesk as they're basically
going through the tickets we're giving
them recommendations about how to
respond and if they don't like those
recommendations they can search and
figure it out and it seems sort of very
simple it's sort of abstracted at the UI
level but you have to think about your
audience right you have to think about
you build these and deploy these new
ways of doing machine learning and
production what's the impact I think it
was about a week ago that maybe two
weeks ago that the the gmail group said
we're using deep learning now and look
how great the ROC curves are getting for
all of our people using our spam filter
and you know it's pretty impressive and
then a couple days later linus torvalds
posted this he said something you did
recently has been an unmitigated
disaster of the roughly thousand spam
threads I've gone through so far now 228
threads were incorrectly marked as spam
Google pissed off Linus he didn't like
he didn't like his ROC curve I mean
let's face it Google is the best machine
learning company in the world and they
sometimes struggle at what is one of
their core end user facing products and
machine learning and it isn't just
Google Netflix also makes this mistake
sometimes this was on reddit a couple
days ago is this fault-tolerant ml yeah
I mean this guy isn't going to cancel as
his subscription Linus isn't going to
stop using Gmail this is very very hard
stuff and one of the things that Leon
said in icml was that machine learning
disrupt software engineering so what
should be the machine learning
engineering process you know that my
scaling curve is better than your
scaling curve is not the answer or my
you know version of this algorithm has a
slightly better accuracy than this you
have to have and this is the scary part
of it all you have to have a fifty
thousand foot view of the entire system
as you're building out and working on
these various different components it's
not an intractable problem it's a really
hard problem and I guarantee you it's
not going to be solved by one type of
person and really the last thought here
the parting thought is that when it
comes to ml systems it takes a village
or another way to say this is data
science as a team sport you have to have
interdisciplinary teams and this should
echo for those that were there the
keynote this morning
some of the things that you heard there
of the cry for that we often talk about
in academia that need to build these
pie-shaped people who are like really
good at domain questions and really good
computer scientists and PhDs and
everything and my view of this world is
that there isn't this notion of a pie
shaped person it's dangerous from an
educational perspective to be thinking
about how we create pie-shaped people we
need to create people that are very deep
in something and maybe some deep in some
other parts and we need to get a bunch
of gamma people together and gamma
shaped people to solve some real world
problems so unless you haven't been
paying attention you know I think it's
it's reasonable to say that you know
just because you've got a good software
package that implements a whole bunch of
machine learning algorithms it doesn't
mean that that's a functioning ml system
there are many other considerations when
you build these ml systems it better be
because it's the last resort because you
have to what I like to say is if it's
not worth doing it's not worth doing
well machine learning systems require
optimizations across components so we
better understand the true loss function
not just in our restricted domain but at
the largest level and hopefully this
isn't a completely lost problem and the
novel novel testing frameworks can
strengthen those abstractions within
components and the contracts between
them and regardless of what you do the
last sort of line of defense is some
notion of a fault-tolerant machine
learning so with that I'll say thank you